there is a frantic search operation
underway in tennessee after that
record-breaking rain and a devastating
flood at least 22 people are dead and
many more are missing now we're learning
more about the sudden and tragic losses
involved there jesse mitchell is in
waverly where the water rose very
quickly on saturday and they're still
trying to clean up and dig out jesse
good morning
good morning tony four days after this
historic flood the town of waverly
tennessee still looks like this in just
about every direction we're hearing more
heartbreaking stories about friends and
family members swept away
rachel reeves parents tried to escape as
eight feet of flood waters inundated
their house right as they left the door
my dad got rushed into the rapids and my
sister and mom they all got separated
rachel's father did not survive his body
was found a mile from the home he died a
hero he saved my mom and sister and i
know he's resting peacefully because of
that
rachel's mother and sister made their
way to the top of separate buildings and
were rescued by a volunteer flying a
private helicopter there was debris that
they floated on all the way down there
shyanna bryant's year old sister lily
has been missing for four days now she
was last seen grabbing onto debris
trying to stay afloat i'm hoping that
maybe she's with somebody just
unconscious and not able to
tell them like a number or she's alive
and just somewhere we can't get to her
more than 20 bodies have already been
recovered including that of wayne spears
a long time friend and ranch foreman for
country legend loretta lynn taylo lynn
is lin's granddaughter being wayne and
being our
ranch heartbeat was out there trying to
get the dadgum tractor
out of harm's way and that water just
like everything that happened here in
town it just came so fast i had
the twins in my arms like this danielle
hall and matthew rigney experienced the
unthinkable when their twins ryan and
raeliana were swept away from their
father's arms by the sudden surge of
water in their apartment never ever
imagine we would be burying two babies
that are seven months
the rigney family had just moved into
their home two weeks before the flood so
did rachel reeves parents and gail
tomorrow services will begin for that
beloved ranch foreman wayne spears and
the two baby twins
all right jessie mitchell reporting
thank you so much listen all the losses
are devastating when you lose someone in
your family but every time you look at
the pictures those two twin girls it's
very very tough all right and the
families that are together and then
separated by the water yeah it's another
reminder about the force of mother
nature never ever ever
know that there's still a lot of missing
people exactly holding out hope for that
one girl is still missing